ちゃんとしなさい
こういうふうに小さい頃親から言われたことがあるって人
てあげてください
結構アレ書揃いなんですね
安心しました僕の小さい頃
ちゃんとしなさいって親に言われて関西人のちょっと血が騒いだもあるんですけど
ちゃんとってなんやねんって用途ばっかりしてました
けど
何なんか言った後かなんかされたも生編っていう親と今妻がました後からお菓子買って
もらうかも知れ
誘惑の前に結局親のユイコ
に
てしていました
周りに完璧主義な人が多かったこともあって僕は小さい頃
b 子であることを強く教えられました
そしていい子になるにはいい行動しないといけない
そう言われましたん
けど狡猾だった僕は嫌
嘘ついた方がえんちゃうということに気づきました
ん
テスト30点行ったれって本当なことを言って何やってんのって怒られるよりテスト
100点行ったでって嘘をついた方が最終的にあっ行くやろうって言ってもらえたわけ
です
んな簡単に良い子すごいって言ってもらえるに行ったら嘘ついた方がいい
そう思った理由は
見栄を張るための嘘これを築いていくようになりました
小学校の時指ようっていうカードゲームに僕ははまっていました
ん
カードゲームにはみんながうらやむレアカードがありますと
そのレアカード僕は持っていないのに持っている
うそをつきましたん
形からなぁうらやましいなって言われて僕は嬉しかったです
けどハプニングが起こりますとん
この回は横で聞いていた私を好きな妹がいたんです
その妹がと月にこう言いますとこの日は嘘ついてんでこんなカードも店
と言われておけば
ここで言うなよな
思っちゃって結局その嘘はバレてしまいました
けど見栄を張りたかった僕はこのように嘘をついて
そしてばれ続けた結果
学校の時
僕はいじめを受けました
スポーツ
消えろ
誰か言われてつらかったです
この時に僕が反省していやこれから素直になろうと思えた良かったんです
けどひねくれていた僕は嫌
次は絶対にバレへん嘘をつこう
そう思って多くは嘘を極めるような道を選んでいきますと
ん
例えば将来の夢を聞かれた時です
相手にすごいと言ってもらえるようにいろんなことを考えますと
ん
まずは相手の性格年齢性別から相手が何を正しいと思う傾向にあるのかをだいたい絞り
ます
これで大体夢は何言ってき空や時のすごいなお前と言われるような答えは見つかります
けどたまになんでって興味を持って聞いてくれる人がいますよね
内心めちゃめちゃ嬉しいんですけど
嘘つきにとってはこれ結構厄介なんですよね
深彫りをされたときはその夢が何でそういう夢につながっているのか論理的に語らない
といけません
相手が考えているであろうことをくみ取りながら
ん
の過去時には熱通して相手にあったからだって納得してもらわないといけません
医者になりたいっていう意味一つでもそうです
金稼ぎしたいかとか勉強できたか
理由で納得してくれると思います
けど熱い思いで語らないと納得してくれない人だっています
インドに行った時
病院の前に何人もの人が並んでるのを言いますとん
そこでその一つ位みんな何時間をご覧に並ぶの診療を受けられるけどその質が
めちゃくちゃ悪いから結局死んでいく人もいる
そんな現状を聞いて僕は地球上のこの1+9位タイだから1歳になったんだ
こんな感じで熱い気持ちを語ることで納得してくれると思います
何を伝えるかだけではなくてどのようにして伝えるかいつもついを払っていました
このようにしてついた巧妙な嘘ですごいって言ってもらえるのはめちゃくちゃ嬉しかっ
たです
自分に嘘さえつけば家も貼れるすすごいとも入ってもらえる
こんな高こんな a ことないやんって思ってどんどんどんどん自分に嘘をついて行き
ますと
そしてすごいねとか尊敬してるなんて言われるのは日常になってきたとき
どこか僕はどこか僕は
生きづらさを感じるようになっていきました
ん
小さい時あんなにすごいと言われたくてやっとすごい
言ってもらえたのに
生きづらさを感じてばっかりいました
高校2年の夏のある日
そうして僕は学校休みますん
生には体調不良ですとメールを送ります
本当は
こうにも行けないくらい心がボロボロになっていたから
僕の部屋には本棚があります
本がびっしりと並べられています
けどその日僕のホンダ日本はありませんでした
床に散乱していますと
気づけば1日前の夜ホンダのの方全部僕が引きダイヤして床に散乱させていたからです
おやなにも言わずに学校を休ませてくれますとん
けどこの時初めて
今まで関していた生きづらさを目の当たりにします
次の日僕は縋るようにある先生のところに行きますと
ん
その先生は高1のときの担任で思っていることを妻というような先生ですと
職員室でその先生を読んで僕は関していた生きづらさを打ち明けました
ん
そうしたらその先生はペンとポストイットを持ってなにゃこんな図を書き始めました
そして編成はこう言いますと
お前は
人かな凄いとか言われるためにアクセサリーあせめて磨いてるだけよ
この言葉とこのずに僕は心をグサリと刺されますと
それまで僕は人からすごいいいねぇとか言われる
称賛三重というアクセサリーを集めてばかり言いますと
相手に嘘をついて自分に嘘をついて見栄を張って満足していました
けどそれはその場しのぎにはなっても
ドンドンドン心と体を蝕んでいくだけです
いくらすごいって周りの人から言われてもそれは自分に対する嘘で作り出すと嘘の自分
の子形でしかなくて
運動の自分が認められていたわけではなかったからです
それに加えて相手によって嘘をついているのが違うかったためにいつも何のウソついた
かなって考えながら生きないといけないことに疲れていました
どうやった自分のことを良く見せられるかな
毎日人と会うたびに移設しているような気分です
文に素直に生きられていないし嘘ばっかり付かないといけない
だから聞づらさを感じていたんだ
僕はその先生とこのずにそういうことを教わりました
ん
この先生との会話の後
アフと幼稚園の時の幼なじみのことを思い出しました
ん
その後はバレーで小さい頃菓子をたくさんもらっていて
人一倍バレーの練習をしていましたん
な彼女今は海外でバレリーナとして活躍しているそうです
僕から見て彼女は素直にバレーのことが好きだったんだと思います
好きなことで認められるような努力をしていました
ん
な彼女と僕は対照的ですと
認められる為に自分に嘘をついて見栄を張って生きていました
ん
それで生きづらさを感じていました
そのように自分に嘘をつかずに自分がやりたいことで認められるような人生を生きたい
そう思ってっ
これから自分に素直になろう
そう思うきっかけになりましたん
そんな僕が今持ってる夢の一つは
一人でも多くの人が生きづらさを感じずに生きられる世界を作ることです
絆さ
ふうに対してついている嘘見えからくることがあります
だからこそもしこの世の中についてはいけない嘘があるとしたら
うんをアザラク自分を誇示するような嘘です
のに素直になってより一人でも多くの人が来づらさを感じるに生きていければいいなと
思います
そして最後に
今生きづらさを感じているなっていう人いや生きづらさ感じでないっていう人それぞれ
に向けて伝えたいことがあります
まずは今生きづらさを感じているなと思っている人に向けてです
普段の言動で
自分のことを誇示しよいいように見えようと思っていませんか
もしかしたらその生きづらさはそうした自分に対するそう
三重から来ているのかもしれません
そんな時は
ぜひ勇気を持って周りの友達にそのことを伝えてみてください
どうしたら
今生きづらさを感じているそんなことと
軍が今自分についているこそがどのように関連しているのかアドバイスをもらえるはず
です
そして次に今生きづらさを感じてないしむしろ
素直に生きられているな思っている人に向けてです
そんな皆さんにはお願いがあります
持っ
友達が生きづらいで告白してきたとき
生きづらさを感じているなって気づいた時
真剣に相談に乗ってあげてください
そして何より
なかなか人には言いづらいような弱みや見栄というものを安心して打ち明けられるよう
な雰囲気や関係作りを心がけてほしいと思います
それはたとえば積極的に自己開示をすることかもしれませんし
一緒に何か失敗してこんなダメなとこもある年でっていうふうに積極的教えてあげる
ことかもしれません
文をさらけだせるような雰囲気こそ今自分に嘘をついて生きづらさを感じている人に
とって何よりも大切なことなんです
いづらさを感じるまで自分に嘘をついて生きる人なんてそんな必要はない
そう思っていても確かです
けど
実際そうやって自分に嘘をついている人
使わないといけないと思っている人がたくさんいるのも事実です
だからこそ
自分が思っていることすなあになってもいいんだよと安心させてあげられるような関係
を作ることが生きづらさを感じずにいろんな人が生きていけるような社会を作るために
は
何よりも大切なことだと僕は思います
ご静聴ありがとうございました
[拍手]